hi i'm catherine mccord from welicious
and this is pro tips from pro chefs
[Music]
i'm going to show you some tsa approved
recipes that are so simple to make and
with these hacks and tips it's going to
make preparing these recipes a breeze
here's how to do it this is one of my
favorite recipes to make when i travel
because first of all it's only three
ingredients you're going to take a flour
tortilla about this size but if you have
something smaller or larger that's going
to work too you're going to take peanut
butter and then of course your banana so
start by taking your tortilla on a flat
surface and then you're just going to
take some good creamy peanut butter but
my kids they like a lot of peanut butter
so i give it a nice coating all across
and just spread spread spread you can
even go to the very edge right here
because you're going to be rolling it up
having a protein a fruit and a
carbohydrate really will save you for
hours and hours and of course like i
said it's tsa approved no one's going to
stop you unless of course someone wants
a bite so with a banana i always
recommend trying to find a straight
banana now finding a straight banana not
always easy but
i think we'll go with this one so
peel your banana and again you want to
make sure that you have a banana that's
nice and sweet so place it in the side
closest to you
and take the tortilla and press it with
the peanut butter and slowly rolling it
up
pushing the tortilla on all sides
against that banana and just keep
pulling it towards you and make tight
tight tight and then again you've got
that peanut butter right there that is
your glue
so just put it face down
and then you want a serrated knife and i
almost like to do this like sushi
this is like sushi you'll see when i
show you in the middle and then just
turn it like this so nice even sized
pieces and you can make them smaller or
larger i like to say about one inch
oh aren't they cute look at this
i just want you to see look at that
you've got that beautiful banana right
in the middle so sweet but you've also
got the like kind of saltiness from the
peanut butter now let's also talk about
containers because you want to make sure
that when you're traveling especially if
you're traveling with kids that you keep
them busy and you keep their bellies
full so that they don't have those like
sugar just crashes in the middle of the
flight no one needs that especially not
me so i like to use a bento box
container like this so a bento box
container like this is a huge help
because not only can you see all of your
choices but it's got a divider in the
middle but it's great because you can
just put these little banana dog bites
right in like this
so that they'll stay separated
nice and fresh and then you have it for
the flight to wherever you're going and
then whenever you get somewhere and
you're ready to fly back you can refill
it i've got strawberries and blueberries
i've got the banana dog bites you have
got a full complete meal right here and
super affordable too
[Music]
when you're traveling through tsa these
cookies are a mouthful of good for you
food the last thing i want are foods
that leave crumbs all over my seat
that's why these breakfast cookies are
like magic they have just this nice
little bit of chew so
no crumbs they're packed with protein
from pistachios and the flax seeds which
are also packed with omega-3 fatty acids
there's no refined sugar they're made
with applesauce and maple syrup and
they've got dried cherries and
pistachios but you could also just go
wild and add chocolate chips or any of
your other favorite nuts but they're
also great to just freeze and take with
you on the go
whenever i want to really impress my
kids especially when we're traveling i
make this blackberry tea cake it's
really sweet cuts beautifully into
squares and it has this like jewel that
you find in every single bite so here's
how to do it you're gonna butter and
flour your pan and then after it cools a
little bit you're gonna flip it out okay
i heard it flip so that's a good sign
and then
it's so much fun to make
and when you cut it
look at this
you get these like perfect little bites
of blackberry in every bite it's really
stable so that you can just cut it into
squares pack it in any kind of zipper
bags or foil carry it right on the plane
one of the best things about this
blackberry tea cake is it's not crumbly
you can just open a bite of it
and look at that
all these beautiful blackberries in
every bite and no mess when you're
traveling you better hope that your
neighbor sitting in the seat next to you
doesn't try to steal a bite
for more pro tips head to the
drewbarramoreshow.com
slash pro tips and if you make any of
these recipes tag me
licious hashtag drewbarrowmore show
this was so much fun i hope everybody
has a great time traveling thanks for
having me drew see you soon
[Music]